[Musique]
depuis le 24 février 2022 à la
télévision sur les réseaux sociaux on
assiste en direct à des combats acharnés
dans les villes
ukrainiennes avant la guerre en Ukraine
la lutte contre daesh a elle aussi été
rythmée par des opérations dans des
villes du Mali de Syrie ou d'Irak
Stalingrad Berlin gros Fallouja Gao
mosouaka la bataille urbaine marque
l'histoire des conflits de ces 80
dernières années la guerre sera-t-elle
désormais urbaine comment et avec quel
moyen fait-on la guerre en ville dans ce
journal de la défense des civils et des
militaires racontent de l'Intérieur leur
combat en milieu
[Musique]
urbain
depuis 2 ans de guerre en Ukraine la
ville est au cœur de l'action encerclé
bombardé parfois rasé elle est un
théâtre d'opération
privilégié en octobre 2022 le ministre
des Armées Sébastien lecnu annonce une
vaste offre de formation pour plusieurs
milliers de soldats Ukrainiens avec au
programme notamment de l'entraînement au
combat urbain une demande spécifique de
l'Ukraine le nom des batailles l'Ukraine
sont des noms de
villes les on s'est battu pour Kerson on
s'est battu pour Mario Paul évidemment
on s'est battu pour carkif Kief et
ceetera donc c'est l'enjeu de cette
guerre ce sont les villes maintenant la
ville est redevenue un lieu de champ de
bataille et je dirais même le lieu de
champ de bataille privilégié des combats
modernes
depuis pratiquement enfin la Seconde
Guerre mondiale voilà c'est là que
véritablement euh on a commencé à donner
des des noms de grandes villes comme
lieu de bataille comme stalingrade
évidemment Berlin et d'autres
puis avec l'urbanisation croissante des
des sociétés bah forcément mécaniquement
bah vous rencontrez de plus en plus de
villes et les villes sont des endroits
où on
peut se protéger en réalité le mieux de
toute la puissance de feu de la nu
quand on regarde effectivement dans
l'histoire des conflits l'histoire des
guerres la ville n'a pas toujours été le
lieu des batailles historiquement on
assiégeit une ville on la défendait on
combattait autour mais on y combattait
rarement à l'intérieur c'est vraiment au
début du 20e siècle que la ville devient
un champ de bataille et on commence à
voir dans les conflits à travers le
monde vraiment la conduite d'opération
d'envergure dans cet environnement
urbain au milieu des années 90 vous Ava
des événements un peu particul comme le
siège de sarevour ou en dehors des
Balcans mais la guerre de la bataille de
grosen qui alimente une réflexion dans
plusieurs pays dont la France sur les
engagements en zone urbaines et la
nécessité de se doter de d'outils
d'entraînement et de développer des
doctrines
spécifiques il y a près de 30 ans en
avril
1992 la ville de Sarajevo en
Bosnie-Herzégovine est assiégée sous
mandat de l'ONU la France envoie des
soldats protéger les populations civiles
dans la capitale bosniaque dont le
colonel Michel Goya alors lieutenant
chef de section au 21e régiment
d'infanterie de marine ce qui m'avait
frappé c'est euh en réalité lorsqueon é
rentré dans la ville c'est le le vide de
de cette ville c'estàdire que là vous
avez une ville en guerre euh au ville
siégé en réalité ben vous voyez personne
quoi ou très peu de gens quoi parce que
tout le monde se cache tout simplement
he donc donc vous avez donc il y a pas
de circulation par exemple euh donc vous
avez l'impression d'être dans une ville
fantôme euh les seuls bruits que vous
entendez ce soit quelques bruits de de
véhicules qui étaient souvent les nôtres
qui se déplaçaient et les bruit des
balles et des obus c'est donc c'est ça
vous plonge dans un contexte même
cognitif même sensoriel qui est
complètement différent de d'une ville
normale
quoi la ville recevait en moyenne 250
auus chaque jour donc c'est une
derilleur au passage c'est une dernière
grande expérien que l'on a de de d'être
pr sous sous le feu de l'artillerie à
grande échelle c'est une ville tout en
longueur avec un acte central qui est
qui a été baptisé sniper allé parce
qu'il était sous le feu des des snipers
quand on est arrivé B d'ailleurs ça a
pas loupé on est arrivé 2h au bout de 2h
on a déjà perdu un soldat qui avait été
frappé
par par un tireur probablement bosniaac
d'ailleurs et donc parmi les problèmes
tactiques qu'on a eu à à résoudre c'est
le problème voilà comment comment on
fait pour faire face à ces gens qui nous
tirent dessus de depuis des maisons euh
avec cette contrainte qu'on a pas le
droit en tant que casque bleu d'aller
dans les maisons donc on peut juste se
défendre de de contre ces gens-là qui
nous tire dessus donc il y a tout un tas
de savoir-faire qu'il a fallu inventer
réinventer en réalité passer les détails
mais c'est un combat assz assez
compliqué euh où il faut tout
cartographier il faut tout analyser il
faut un combat de statistique il faut
analyser les les les sons des des balles
pour savoir d'où d'où
viennent les tir je vous donne juste
juste un petit un exemple ce qui m'a
aidé en réalité à ce moment-là c'est que
j'avais toujours avec moi le manuel du
sous-officier d'infanterie de
1949 qui était plein de
savoir-faire de l'époque très concret
daté de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
don certain n av été oublié donc c'est
comme ça que j'ai appris comment
distinguer les bruits des balles euh
entre distinguer le bruit de la
détonation de départ euh qui arrive vers
vous à la vitesse du son hein forcément
donc 300 m/s c'était du combat de fantô
hein on tire sur des zones on calcule
c'est le combat du calcule on calcule
d'où ça vient et puis à partir de là on
tire sur sur des points sur des points
précis à l'époque j'avais pris quelqu'un
qui dessinait bien et on avait dessiné
tout toute la zone qui était autour de
nous donc ça a pris un certain temps
mais il avait dessiné exactement tous
les bâtiments toutes les fenêtres et
cetera puis j'avais baptisé chacune des
maisons des immeubles et j'avais
numéroté chacune des fenêtres et donc et
et ce ce dessin on l'avait photocopié
donc ce ce schéma on le trouvé un peu
près partout et donc quand on
communiquait entre nous ben je disais
voilà ben feu sur le bâtiment Maurice
Maurice i donc ça indiqué une fenêtre
précise voilà que tout le monde pouvait
voir et en même temps j'avais pris le
temps de d' analyser toutes les
distances donc tout on appelle ça un
baptème terrain donc les tireurs
n'avaient qu'à à mettre sur leur sur le
lunettes ils avaient à régler en
fonction de de la distance et pour
pouvoir tirer le plus vite
possible et donc les années 90 c'est
l'époque où en réalité presque toutes
les grandes armées modernes se se
prépare à ce type de combat on crée des
des centres spécifiques euh pour
s'entraîner à ce combat dont on pressent
que ce sera le le vraiment le le le
combat le plus difficile à mener dans
les années à venir c'est effectivement
en 1999 qui est décidé par les armées
françaises par ministère des armées la
création d'un centre d'entraînement aux
actions zones urbaines qui sera implanté
ici sur le camp de Sisson je dispose de
moyens très spécifiques des instructeurs
spécialisés sur pour accompagner les
unités au combat dans dans
l'entraînement une compagnie interarme
de force adverses qui dont la mission
est de de jouer l'adversaire sur les
entraînements des infrastructures comme
celle que vous pouvez voir derrière moi
qui sont uniques en France et en Europe
et un système de simulation et
d'animation du champ de bataille
particulièrement
moderne ces fantassins du Régiment de
marche du Tchad ent leur 3è semaine de
formation avant leur déploiement en
Roumanie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
auè étage une équipe je progresse états
super ok de de
et 41 orange alors c'est mission
offensive de s'emparer de la zone
moderne de Geoffrey court donc c'était
une manœuvre coordonnée avec tout le
groupement tactique Inter avec un appui
de nos alliés belges et nous nous
devions nous emparer du sud vers le nord
de la zone moderne c'est ce que nous
avons fait une attaque
d'abord une grande phase préalable de ce
qu'on appelle de bouclage où finalement
on enserque un petit peu la ville à
distance pour renseigner un maximum sur
ce qui se passe dans la ville où est
positionné l'ennemi où est-ce qu'il y a
des mines ou est-ce qu'il n'y a pas de
mines afin de pouvoir préparer ensuite
notre engagement par des tir artillie
artillerie pour qu'il y ait un ennemi
qui soit plus faible et pour identifier
notre axe d'approche et ensuite une fois
qu'on a fait cette phase là il y a la
phase d'abordage d'assaut proprement
parl où là c'est les sections
d'infanterie qui font plutôt en tête qui
qui sont appuyés par des éléments de
génie pour leur ouvrir les obstacles et
dépiéger s'il y a besoin de dépiéger et
ensuite ça se fait successivement
bâtiment après bâtiment de manière très
coordonnée et donc c'est assez complexe
parce que en zone urbaine la menace peut
venir de de tout àimut et aussi au
niveau de la 3D en dessous à gauche à
droite devant
derrière ce qui est certain c'est qu'un
le milieu urbain c'est un milieu qui est
particulièrement agressif sur deux
dimensions la première c'est la
dimension physique quand on passe sa
journée à monter descendre les étages
passer par des fenêtres des portes et
cetera dans des conditions qui sont qui
sont pas faciles physiquement c'est
extrêmement engageant c'est extrêmement
astraignant ensuite c'est un combat qui
est fatiguant psychologiquement parce
que la menace elle est
omnidirectionnelle l'ennemi peut venir
de partout il peut être partout il est
proche quand on est confronté à un
ennemi qui est à courte distance on va
s'y affronter peut-être le premier jour
mais ce sera nécessaire de reconduire
cette cette cet engagement le lendemain
le surlendemain et pendant une durée qui
qui peut être très longue on a entendu
notamment sur les les rtex de bakmou en
Ukraine des progressions qui étaient de
l'ordre de la dizaine de mètres par jour
on se rend bien compte que le milieu est
abrasif qui permet pas une progression
aussi rapide que sur un terrain ouvert
et ça ajoute à la difficulté et physique
et
psychologique si l'ennemi à à un groupe
qui est déployé il va falloir une
compagnie en face pour pouvoir mettre un
un terme pour pouir affronter ce groupe
là on a un rapport qui est estimé à 1
contre 6 7 là où en terrain ouvert on a
un rapport de force qui est estimé à 1
contre 3 et c'est la raison pour
laquelle par exemple des organisations
armées où les vont se réfugier vont
s'installer dans des villes c'est un
multiplicateur de de force pour le
défenseur c'est un diviseur de de force
pour l'attaquant c'est un diviseur de
puissance de feu c'est une sorte de zone
fortifiée c'est un grand
fort qui a été construit par des civils
d'une certaine façon euh qui est en
trois dimensions et euh on est sur des
zones qui sont solides c'est
Durin taper franchir percer des des des
bâtiments des grands bâtiments c'est il
faut il faut mettre le paquet moi j'ai
passé une mission dans la ville de Saro
pendant le siège on était dans un
complexe sportif on recevait des obus
toute la journée sur ce complexe et ça
résistait le Centre abrite un site
d'instruction unique en son genre le
complexe de tir en zone urbaine au total
h champs de tir mais ici rien de fictif
l'entraînement se fait à balle
réel au-delà des constructions qui
matérialisent un environnement urbain
nous avons à partir de cette tour de
contrôle la capacité d'animer nos nos
champs de tir et donc de ramener au plus
près l'entraînement du combattant dans
des conditions qui se rapprocheront de
des territoires d'opération et donc de
la réalité de l'engagement par des des
bruits de fond des sonorités spécifiques
des bruits de combat des passages
d'hélicoptères d' avion de chasse ce
genre d'environnement mais également des
appuis lumineux ou à contrario des
gênnes que l'on retrouverait sur un
territoire d'opération urbain tel que la
pollution résiduelle de l'éclairage
public des flashes d'explosion ou ce
genre de choses on retrouve dans ce
complexe de tir en zone urbaines tout un
tas d'environnements qui nous permettent
de nous mettre dans des situations
d'inconfort au tir et bien évidemment
réagir à une mise en situation d'une
d'une de vivre une embuscade donc de
réagir et de se désengager d'une
embuscade de par notre expertise nous
avons également une vocation à observer
et à tirer les enseignements de des
conflits en cours et des engagements en
zone urbaines qui pourraient se se
produire à travers le monde de la même
manière que nous échangeons avec
d'autres pays qui développent des
structures équivalentes de manière à
adapter nos scénarios d'entraînement à
faire évoluer l'environnement dans
lequel on entraîne les unités pour
rester le plus réaliste possible et
coller au plus près de ce que les unités
pourraient rencontrer sur le terrain en
opération et quand on observe euh les
conflits de ces 20 dernières années euh
l'Irak le sud Liban le Sahel et
aujourd'hui en Ukraine cela confirme
effectivement toute la pertinence et
l'intérêt pour la France de disposer
d'un d'un centre d'entraînement
spécialisé dans le combat en zone
urbaine il y a 10 ans en janvier 2013 la
France lance l'opération Serval pour
bloquer la progression des groupes
diihadistes au
le 21 février le 92e régiment
d'infanterie combat dans la ville de Gao
un enseignement important pour moi au
sortir de cette de ce qu'on a appelit la
bataille de Gao sur la journée du 21
février 2013 c'est que le passage que
mon sousgroupement avait pu faire au
subassisson en novembre 2012 il aevêtu
une importance don j'avais pas forcément
conscience dès le
départ mais il m'a appris il nous a
appris collec ement tout ce qu'on avait
besoin de savoir pour être efficace en
zone urbaine ce pourquoi on a été
entraîné c'est quasiment exactement ce
qui nous est arrivé et donc quand on est
arrivé sur le terrain et qu'on a dû
intervenir je pense qu'on a été assez
efficace à cette époque là j'étais
capitaine un capitaine de d'infanterie
c'est donc un officier qui commande à
peu près 180 fantassins divisé en C
sections et puisque cette compagnie
d'infanterie avait été transformée en en
agrégeant des renforts en sousgroupement
tactique interarme j'avais sous mes
ordres à peu près 250 personnes 250
combattants de différentes armes j'avais
avec moi une équipe du CP A3 donc des
commandos parachutistes de l'air qui
assurit la liaison avec la composante
aérienne et aviation légère de l'armée
de terre en plus de ces gens de l'armée
de l'air et en plus de ces gens de la
lat j'avais avec moi des sapeurs du 31e
régiment du génie qui ont été
incroyables de sang frroid et
d'efficacité et ben ce qui s'est passé
le 21 février c'est que durant la nuit
alors que la ville avait été
libérée et que la population avait
repris sa vie normale sa vie quotidienne
les djihadistes d'un mouvement qui
s'appelait le le mjao sont arrivés pour
s'installer en défense ferme dans le
centre ville dans l'hypercentre de Gao
qui est un un centre avec des des
constructions qui datent de l'airre
coloniale et des murs qui sont d'une
d'une épaisseur terrible et qui donc
constitue autant de défenses très
efficace contre un assaillant donc c'est
des des points quasiment fortifiés
naturellement à l'entrée de la ville on
a été recueilli par quelques éléments
français qui faisaient ce qu'on appelle
du mentoring au profit de l'armée
malienne et qui ont pu nous donner
quelques premiers éléments de contexte
euh quelques directions générales dans
cette direction le fleuve à gauche la
population une zone sécurisée à droite
de cet axe la zone des combats les
positions tenues par les dihadistes et
et en fait les positions dont il faut
vous emparer pour moi c'était simple je
savais que la population avait été u et
que tout ce qui se présenterait à moi
dans le compartiment qu'on m'avait
attribué c'était à détruire et que
c'était de l'ennemi donc c'était
relativement simple la vraie difficulté
qu'on a pu connaître c'est que l'habitat
avait été piégé massivement piégé par
les djihadistes du Mujao avec des
grenade avec de l'explosif avec du fil
piège et que doncon m'a pas autorisé à
prendre pied dans les bâtiments et donc
je devais combattre depuis les
extérieurs ça veut dire rester sur les
axes le bâtiment c'est une zone inconnue
mais c'est aussi à partir du moment où
on l'a sécurisé c'est un appui possible
pour progresser vers des objectifs
ultérieurs se regrouper faire le point
se réapprovisionner en
munition réfléchir aux ordres qu'on va
donner et là c'était pas possible donc
on était exposé en fait au tir en
permanence je comprends que exactement
comme on l'a appris lorsqu'on était à
l'entraînement au sansub centre
d'entraînement aux actions en zone
urbaine de Sisson mes véhicules blindés
mes VBCI vont mêre précieux puisque en
fait il constitue à la fois un appui feu
redoutable terriblement efficace mais
que en fait ce sont des espèces de
rempar sur roue c'est des rempars
mobiles ils sont très blindés très
solides très protecteurs et puis comme
ils sont haut il nous permettent en
grimpant dessus d'avoir des visions
possibles au-dessus des murs sur les
terrasses et ainsi de suite et de
prendre pied dans le bâti si nécessaire
l'infanterie c'est une arme de mêlée
c'est une arme qui va au contact qui va
au plus près de l'adversaire de l'ennemi
et en fait qui va qui va dans la bagarre
qui va se battre de très très près pas à
distance mais vraiment au contact on dit
que c'est l'arme des 300 derniers mètres
on se mettra en ligne le long du muret
là-bas sur la gauche ok allez on avant
c'est aussi surtout l'arme des derniers
mètres et on dit qu'on va chercher
l'ennemi à la fourchette c'est vraiment
ça en fait et on s'est battu au pistolet
on s'est battu à la grenade on s'est
battu au fusil d'assaut on s'est battu
au lanceroquet on s'est battu au canon
mitrailleur et et le dernier ordre que
j'aurais pu donner c'est bayonette au
canon je l'ai pas donné mais en fait
l'occasion se serait présenter
effectivement à Gao ce
jour-là on sort de là on étant épuisé
soulagé on est fier de la mission
remplie parce qu'on sait à ce moment-là
que la mission est
[Rires]
remplie en octobre 2016 les forces
irakiennes appuyées par les combattants
kurdes et la coalition dont les
États-Unis et la France font partie
lancent une offensive pour reconquérir
Mossou la deuxè ville d'irac et chassé
daesh au-delà de de la reconquête de son
terrain l'objectif de la coalition
c'était bien de de de s'emparer du
symbole qui était la ville de Moussou
puisque c'est là qu'en 2014 l'État
islamique avait proclamé son califat
voilà donc au-delà de l'objectif terrain
il y avait l'objectif immatériel qui
était la la saisie la saisie de la
capitale de l'État islamique Mossou
c'est la deuxème ville d'Irak c'est une
ville vraiment tentaculaire doit faire à
peu près 2 km Carr euh avec un
centre-ville très dense il est très
difficile d'estimer combien d'habitants
il reste mais dans les différentes
manœuvres qu'on peut faire on voit qu'il
y a encore une grande masse de
population donc avant c'était 2 millions
d'habitants là on est plutôt dans
l'inconnu au moment des opérations et
effectivement on voit que la vie
continue un peu malgré tout on voit des
marchés euh on scrute la la ville rue
par rue et on on voit que voilà il y a
vraiment des la activité quotidienne
mais ça perturbe vraiment les les
opérations à l'époque où le 11e ramasse
se déploie notre mission à ce moment-là
et d'appuyer par le feu les opérations
des iraakiens toute la coalition sait
que du fait de la nature urbaine de
l'objectif la la tâche sera rude alors à
ce momentlà j'étais le le chef opération
du du 11e Rama et à ce titre j'étais
pour mon chef de corps l'officier en
charge de la conception des opérations
et de leur conduite ben Mossou c'est une
ville de 200000 structures 3000 km de
route que l'ennemi a valorisé pendant
près de 2 ans daesh a utilisé des moyens
civils qu'il a détourné essentiellement
des tunneliers des engins de
terrassement pour pour créer des abris
pour pour créer des tranchées pour créer
des caves des dépôts des dépôts avancés
de de matériel il a créé des pièges
également donc pour les militaires que
nous sommes nous savons que en fait la
préparation enfin un terrain défensif
valorisé
comme une zone urbaine et qu'on a
valorisé pendant 2 ans c'est en réalité
un objectif militaire extrêmement
difficile à
conquérir pour reprendre une ville comme
Mossou ça a duré plusieurs mois il a
fallu assurer une permanence H24 jour et
nuit dans toutes condition météo pour
justement appuyer la manœuvre terrestre
et assurer une présence de tout type de
d'avion aussi bien de reconnaissance que
d'appui feu il faut savoir que c'est une
reprise immeuble par iM meuble maison
par maison qui implique de grandes
précautions de la part des troupes au
sol et qui ont pu se retrouver pris sous
de multiples tirs et parfois sans
possibilité de se désengager et c'est
grâce à l' l'arme aérienne que nous nous
pouvons et bien accomplir cette mission
de de reprise de reconquête en milieu
urbain je me rappelle très bien d'être
arrivé sur Mossou de découvrir cet
environnement très très dense euh et
d'avoir délivré tout mon armement parce
que des forces spéciales de la coalition
étaient prises s le feu de daesh et
c'est là que je me suis vraiment senti
utile au terme d'une mission que je qui
est passé en un claquement de
doigt le premier risque auquel on est
exposé c'est c'est la sécurité des vols
c'est-à-dire les potentiels collisions
qui peuvent apparaître entre à paril qui
évoluent dans un volume un volume très
réduit un espace aérien très contraint
il faut savoir que sur quelques
kilomètres carrés il y avait aussi bien
des troupes au sol que une multitude
avions tels que des drones des avions de
reconnaissance et des des avions de
chasse prêts à délivrer le feu si le
besoin était était nécessaire et il y a
pas que nous c'est une coalition donc il
y avait des avions de chasse américains
britanniques tous ces gens dans un même
endroit nécessitent évidemment des
procédures particulières notamment
détagement chaque patrouille a une
altitude qui lui est allouée avant de
rentrer dans la zone et en ressortant
évidemment c'est la déconfliction le le
premier de nos soucis avant de d'opérer
sur ce théâtre en octobre 2016 il y a
une équipe Mosou qui a été mise en place
à la Direction du renseignement
militaire dans cette équipe Mosou on a
beaucoup de spécialistes des analyst
irac mais aussi des interprètes images
pour étudier les images de nos capteurs
les satellites les drones les aéronefs
en tout genre on a aussi des experts en
cartographie des spécialistes de la
recherche en source ouverte l'idée c'est
d'apporter notre connaissance notre
enseignement à la fois vers le haut aux
autorités politiques et militaires pour
les aider à prendre une une décision et
aussi plutôt vers le bas vers les forces
déployées que ce soit les forces
conventionnelles ou les forces spéciales
pour qu'ell puisse agir avec la
meilleure connaissance de leur
environnement sur le
terrain Mosou c'est une ville très
compliquée euh avec beaucoup de sites
sensibles des écoles des mosquées des
hôpitaux des universités pour nous
l'objectif ça va être d'identifier si
daesh exploite certains de ces sites et
si des civils sont également présents
euh si on n'est pas sûr à 100 % on peut
pas mener d'opération en revanche
lorsqu'on sait que daesh exploite
vraiment pleinement ce site on transmet
le dossier à nos forces à celle de la
Coalition pour que le l'objectif soit
traité le plus rapidement possible
au-delà de ces sites la périphérie de
Mosou comporte aussi pas mal de d'usines
agricoes dont les produits peuvent être
utilisés pour la fabrication d'explosifs
et peut-être d'armes chimiques donc ça
ce sont des sites particulièrement
sensibles qui sont qui sont traités et
plus généralement ce qui nous intéresse
également ça va être tout ce qui
concerne la fabrication de mortiers et
de véhicules explosifs ce genre de sites
sont protégés par le droit des conflits
armés par par la Convention de Genève
qui nous interdisent de cibler ce type
de cible donc des édifices religieux
typiquement des barrages des des champs
de des production agricole et en
revanche la protection qui leur est
associée est levée si ces objectifs sont
détournés de leur objectif premier
c'estàdire si l'ennemi s'en sert contre
nous et bien on peut être amené à ouv le
feu sur ce genre d'objectif l'impératif
de l'environnement notamment urbain
c'est qu'il faut une grande précision
moins de 10 m on va dire que notre
armement on soit sûr qu'il impacte au
bon endroit avec un effet de souffle et
de fragmentation qui soit maîtrisé d'où
l'importance d'avoir un armement en
l'occurrence guider GPS ou guider laser
avec une tachche laser qui lui indique
où est-ce qu'il doit impacter et avec
des corps de bombe qui
soit font une détonation forte ou une
détonation plus contenu si on veut
vraiment que la bombe bien ne ne fasse
pas de dégâts autour de de
l'objectif durant mon détachement on
avait h avions sur le parking qui
opérait jour et nuit pour participer à
l'effort multinational et c'était
vraiment un engagement hors du commun
parce que l'environnement
l'était c'est un des plus gros
engagements de ma carrière de pilote
notamment sur Rafal à titre personnel
durant 2 mois j'ai fait entre 20 et 25
missions de guerre quasiment toutes
au-dessus de Mossou en plus pendant 2
mois l'engagement du 11e Rama en Irak en
2017 c'est en terme de nombre de coups
tirés c'est le plus significatif pour la
retirie française depuis l'Indochine on
a tiré avec quatre pièces plus de 5600
coups dans la bataille ce qui n'est pas
exceptionnel mais contte tenu de la
nature de l'ennemi contte tenu de de ses
forces et et de son agressivité c'est
inédit compte tenu des opérations
militaires françaises des 50 dernières
années pour le soldat ça représente 5
mois de posture d'alerte 5 minutes 24h
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 donc des séquences
extrêmement longues avec des des avec un
sommeil particulièrement perturbé et des
nerfs mis à rue d'épreuve je pense que
la ville est un théâtre particulièrement
abrasif et exigeant pour les forces quel
qu'ell soit
et qu'il doit impérativement être pris
en compte pour préparer un système de
force adapté c'est un champ de bataille
privilégié c'est
indéniable est-ce que ça le sera est-ce
que ce sera le champ de bataille je sais
pas répondre à cette question lorsqu'on
a à
combattre on sait la difficulté que
représente le combat au zone urbaine on
sait le coût exorbitant que ça va
représenter en engagement en vie en
dommage en énergie euh en temps sans
résultat assurés en fait euh et donc
s'engager en ville c'est toujours
prendre un risque gigantesque et je
pense que on est heureux de d'éviter au
maximum les affrontements en onurmède
mais
malheureusement si l'EMI retranché ben
il faut y aller
[Musique]
quoi